makers coming off back-to-back wins in
Denver and then Utah
LeBron muscling his way to the bucket
against Rodney hood as he goes so go the
Blazers all NBA a season ago LeBron
James with another high hand off its the
highest scoring first quarter for the
Lakers this season with 30 not work
diligently to expand his range should be
more consistent here they are on the
break they got numbers a three on two
Danny Green and another alley-oop this
is like a drill for the Lakers great
targets Danny Green nobody ever stops
the basketball and you gotta have better
decision-making in communication if you
see J and D on inside to Anthony Davis
as a mismatch against Carmelo Anthony
goes right over the top and gets the
soft touch Oh double-team coming
Davis underneath and 180 to work just
like they're coming with three defenders
just Whiteside was in the middle of the
paint there he is
and look at this I mean hood has got it
so automatically you know you've got to
drop down and give some assistance
but it's half-hearted assistance from
Melo I mean if you're gonna double omit
and make them give it up come hard many
counselors win the war but also for
think think about the kind of defense
they played in Indiana get the to
Eastern Conference
good night Oliver and good luck checking
that spit a blazer went right to Dwight
James why not he wanted to shoot that
initial people listening a Damon CJ it
really invested in him Ron working
against Melo James got to the bucket
bosal 11-point lead for the laces trying
to go three you know on this road trip
LeBron knocks down the three Anthony
Davis inside that one's like Ceylon
Davis working one-on-one against
Tolliver spins baseline with the left
and he's up to 19 the meter still
running and flowing that robbed him
Rondo never made it to Davis the Rondo
stole attack Davis corner three and one
a potential four-point play LeBron's
talked about deep pleasure Player of the
Year you might have to MVP candidates on
your team you talked about if they want
him to take more threes Anthony Tolliver
gets his feet tangled on the challenge
they come to the NBA
LeBron inside
made the cats through the foul in one he
feels like he's been hit multiple times
and hasn't gotten the whistle we wanted
this from the outset he wanted the
delivery
[Applause]
he got hit a couple of times yeah weber
state lightly recruited coming out of
high school in Oakland Davis inside over
Carmelo the reason why he was all in DAF
season ago James through the contact of
Whiteside and got it to go dating
ourselves he's got to stop that
that was the fourth foul on base more
LeBron James from beat knocks it in
leadership this year a guy that is the
former most improved player LeBron
another three ball right over hezonia
look at the rotation that's so pretty
I want to scored the last eight for the
Lakers Davis makes a good catch inbounds
a deep hole yes always hotter than fish
grease is cooked but LeBron doing work
right now
Davis hope on the cut cut back hammer
time
to try to get caldwell-pope a look and
the judge he's been nothing short of
remarkable tireless work in raising
funds for the V Foundation three on the
shot clock for Anthony Davis
he's got the sidestep jumper working as
well - this will go home with a perfect
three no road trip nothing wrong with
Anthony Davis's stroke tonight he's up
to 36 now and then telling Mello that
his services are no longer needed and he
has stumbled that's where a lot of
people as LeBron put hezonia in the
weight room I mean it's coming in hot
LeBron on the law express yourself
LeBron James what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content